[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a south korean tv mini
series called nightmare teacher
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
jai su is a junior at yosan high school
in the opening scene he looks into a
mirror and reminds himself of the names
of his close friends he doesn't forget
to mention that a kid named ki tai is
his best friend among the rest but then
when he tries to remember his own name
he seems to be confused the scene shifts
to the school's bathroom jaisu is locked
inside a stall copying answers to the
midterm questions on a note his best
friend kitai is outside banging on the
door asking him to come out because the
period has already started in the
classroom jaisu is nervous because of
the note hidden under his sleeves he
plans to use it to cheat on the midterm
test since jaisu is an academically
talented student he can often predict
what questions are going to be asked in
a test kitai begs him for help to which
jaisu confidently lists a few questions
trusting his friend kitai writes down
the answers to the questions on his desk
just then their homeroom teacher mr han
arrives he officially initiates the
midterm asking them to avoid being the
last one on the rank board before
starting the test he also makes them
change their seats which causes kitai to
end up away from the cheats he had
written the test starts and jaisu
immediately uses the note to cheat mr
han reads a book for the first half of
the test which makes it even easier for
him to copy the answers everything goes
well until jaisu accidentally drops the
note on the floor in the plain sight of
the teacher to help him kitai distracts
mr han by asking him for permission to
go to the bathroom in a moment of panic
jaisu quickly picks up the note and puts
it in his mouth the teacher looks
directly at him and smirks almost as if
he knows what is going on still he
doesn't call them out for cheating then
we are introduced to the president of
the classroom kang yi rim she goes to
the teacher's room to place something on
mr han's desk after making sure no one
is looking at her she goes through his
belongings a student council notebook in
a drawer catches her attention it has a
list of students names from their class
but the column beside jaisu's name has a
question mark on it suddenly mr han
walks in and catches her in the act she
pretends to put something into the
drawer and gets out of the situation
however mr han is not someone who is
convinced so easily he knows that
something about the class president is
off in the following scene ki tai and
jai soo meet at the basketball court
jaisu thanks his friend for saving him
during the test the guys continue
playing basketball when suddenly they
are interrupted by mr han who calls jai
soo to the counseling room jaisu
nervously follows behind and takes a
seat the teacher starts the interview by
asking him how his test went when jaisu
hesitates to answer mr han assumes it
must have gone great since his dearest
friend helped him sarcasm is evident in
the teacher's comment which makes jaisu
even more nervous he starts to cough and
throws the piece of paper he had eaten
into the class when the nervousness gets
the best of him he mentions that he
didn't cheat but the comment only
confirms the teacher's suspicion still
mr han remains calm and offers jaisu a
strange carbonated drink jaisu doesn't
think much before taking it after he
calms down a little the teacher hands
him another sheet of paper and asks him
to answer the questions on it if he
manages to get the same results as he
did in the test his innocence will be
proven and no further actions will be
taken but if he doesn't remember the
answers the principal will be informed
jaisu is so nervous that the paper gets
blurry and he can hardly read the
questions the scene abruptly cuts to an
hour later jaisu is in the library when
kitai arrives and asks him what mr han
said jaisu lies and claims that he just
motivated him to study harder kitai
isn't satisfied with the answer but he
refrains from pushing jaisu to tell the
truth suddenly jaisu runs to the
bathroom to throw up the following day
is the next test while everyone
continues writing as usual jaisu stays
still the teacher makes fun of him and
asks him if he has given up only to find
out that he has already completed the
test surprised he takes a look at the
paper that is filled with all the
answers after the test kitai asks his
friend how it went jaisu smugly replies
that it was way too easy to be a test
some girls from the class including the
class president yo rem are going through
the questions jaisu notices them making
a mistake in the calculation and helps
them with it all of a sudden he starts
seeing blurry again when his vision
clears he forgets the answers he quickly
excuses himself but the strange behavior
doesn't go unnoticed by yo rim jaisu
again goes to the counseling room to
meet mr han the teacher welcomes him in
having already expected his return jaisu
asks him for the soda that he was
offered yesterday because hit made his
memory excellent mr han doesn't hesitate
before telling him that the soda will
cost him his memory he further explains
that the soda replaces the unwanted and
unfruitful memories saved in his brain
with knowledgeable information this
means that over time he might forget
memories that might be meaningful to him
however jaisee doesn't care about the
consequences as long as he gets good
grades after confirming that he is sure
about the process mr han makes him sign
a certificate with his blood the blood
automatically forms his name on the
paper then we see him walking into a
mirror indicating that he has been lured
into the sinister world that mr han has
set the next day jaisu stands in front
of an old vending machine in the school
it has a single memory soda that he
tries to bring out but the machine
doesn't work he shakes it a few times to
get it to work before walking away with
the drink we noticed that all this time
the machine was unplugged the teacher
has also warned him to drink only one
soda a day in the next test jaisu gets
done in the first few minutes and
surprises everyone many students start
to take lessons from him which is
strange to yo rim since she has always
been the first in class
in the following montage we see jaisu
opening several cans of soda and
chugging them down he goes to the
library every day and skims through
books with the ability to memorize
everything with only a glance he doesn't
have to try hard to get good grades for
the rest of the week he aces all the
tests and starts tutoring the best
students of the school one day kitai
approaches him begging to borrow hearts
in a game they often play together but
jai soo who is entirely forgotten about
the game looks at him in surprise he
registers that the soda caused the
memory loss but doesn't stress over it
since he can always learn how to play
the game again the next time he goes to
get the soda he notices something
written on his finger he has asked
himself to get just one can per day
jaisu doesn't remember why the rule
exists and isn't sure if he already
drank a soda that day slowly he starts
forgetting the names of his classmates
whenever he is in class he feels like he
came to the wrong place still he
convinces himself that good grades are
more important one day he finds notes in
his pocket that ask him to end the
contract once the exam is over one of
the notes also says that he shouldn't
trust mr han because he is a swindler
jaisu checks for more notes and finds
his arm filled with writings that help
him remember the basic things he needs
to survive he goes to talk to mr han
again but the man is in no mood to help
instead he assures jaisu that the
memories that are fading are not as
important as the knowledge he is gaining
in turn for them kitai and jaisu are
together during recess kitai has noticed
jaisu's strange behavior in the past
couple of days he calls him out for it
and thinks he is taking illegal pills to
become smarter when jaisu doesn't speak
he asks him if he remembers his best
friend in a monotone voice jaisu answers
that his best friend is ki tai a guy who
is 27th out of 30 students in the class
kitai knows something is off but he can
talk to him about it jaisu excuses
himself and walks away later that day he
is in the library studying for the last
test yo rim ki tai and one of their
classmates watch him from behind the
shelves yorim has caught on to mr han's
strange personality and discovered that
their classmates are going missing
because of him the people who go missing
are erased from everyone's memory which
is why they are never reported kitai
thinks she is bluffing but is genuinely
worried for his friend they follow jaisu
to the vending machine where he gets the
soda for the second time that day the
group is surprised because they had
never noticed the machine until today as
jaisu walks away a can falls out of his
bag he bends down to pick it up
revealing that his bag is filled with
soda cans that he had drank in a single
day the overdose causes him to lose his
memory faster in only a few more hours
he doesn't even remember his name he
somehow ends up in front of his school
but doesn't know if he really goes there
mr han approaches him and tells him his
name before taking him to his class and
pointing at his seat jaisu looks at his
classmates in confusion having
completely forgotten that he has met
them before then he aces the last test
of the midterm and goes to the
counseling room on being asked how he
got there he shows mr han the map on his
arm that he is drawn to help him
remember now that the tests are over he
wants to gain his memory back however mr
han reminds him that it is not possible
according to the contract instead he is
asked to drink another can of soda which
will help him forget everything
altogether jaisu retaliates by saying
that he wants to remember the feelings
he felt towards the people that he loved
mr han smiles and asks him to wait a
little longer in some time he will
forget that he wants to get his memory
back and he won't be as desperate
anymore then the first scene repeats and
jaisu can be seen in front of the mirror
memorizing his friend's names suddenly
he turns back to his normal self and
meets kitai at the basketball court the
two play together like they used to
before the midterms after a while they
lie down to talk kitai suggests that
they go out to the movies in the evening
but jaisu declines stating that he is
busy he bids farewell to his only friend
and goes to meet mr han it turns out
that he was granted his memories back
only for an hour so he could say goodbye
to his friend properly in the last scene
mr han brings jaisu into his world
erasing his existence
forever
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching